The most important detoxification
mineral in the world is not what you
think. And I'm going to reveal it right
here shortly, but I want to see if you
can guess what it is. So, comment down
below. The big mistake that people make
with detoxification is they have this
idea that I have too many toxins. I'm
overloaded with toxins. No, that's not
usually the problem. The problem is you
have a detoxification problem. Your body
is having a difficult time getting rid
of the toxins. This is very different.
If detox was a pyramid, at the very top
would be glutathione. Okay, that is the
master detoxification enzyme of the
entire body. But requires a mineral.
Glutathione doesn't just work in the
liver. It works within every single cell
in your entire body. And it even does a
lot of work in the mitochondria. This is
the energy factory of your body.
Glutathione protects the mitochondria
more than just about everything. So, it
will neutralize things like hydrogen
peroxide. You might have some hydrogen
peroxide in your bathroom where you put
it on a sore and you see it kind of
bubble up and it disinfects certain
things, but your own body makes hydrogen
peroxide to kill off microbes and do
other things and it's very very
corrosive. So, we have glutathione to
help keep it in check so it doesn't end
up damaging your own cells, including
the mitochondria. Glutathione also is
super important in protecting damage in
the membranes of the mitochondria in the
membranes of all of your cells. So this
is a cell and you have a membrane around
it. Well, glutathione is important to
protect that and also you have membranes
around all the different things inside
the cell. Glutathione protects that. It
also protects the DNA of the
mitochondria and it helps other
antioxidants work as well. And I want to
mention something about antioxidants. A
lot of them clean up the damage after
the damage has been done. But
glutathione is preventing the damage
from occurring in the first place. Very
different. And when glutathione is low,
toxins do not leave your body. They get
stuck and then they recirculate. And
this is why people get tired. They feel
depleted. They have brain fog. They get
headaches because they're low in
glutathione. people on keto or when they
lose more weight, they are losing more
fat. And these toxins are stored in the
fat. So, they can come out and you can
feel pretty bad if you don't have enough
glutathione. The most important function
of glutathione is not to protect the
liver. It's to protect the mitochondria
because there's so many diseases that
relate to dysfunctional mitochondria,
especially cancer. The specific area
that these toxins attack on the
mitochondria is this thing right here,
the electron transport chain. Now, what
the heck is that? That's just a part of
the mitochondria, the last part of the
assembly line that helps make ATP or
energy. That's where a lot of toxins
mess up your energy and also in this
membrane that has this mechanism or this
factory inside it. So people that don't
have enough glutathione build up more
toxicity in the mitochondria, then they
can't make energy. Well, guess what? You
need energy to detoxify. So the person
is literally bathing in these toxins and
it's just recirculating and they feel
very, very toxic and especially tired
and they get inflammation and then they
get this idea, oh my gosh, I have too
many toxins. I have to go in another
detox. No, you don't. You need to
strengthen your detoxification system.
And so glutathione helps the fat soluble
toxins go out through the body. Now,
another big toxicity in our bodies is
seed oils because they're highly
inflammatory and they embed into the
membranes. Glutathione helps prevent the
damage to these membranes that are
destroyed from these toxins. Why can't I
just take the supplement glutathione and
just call it a day? Well, the problem is
glutathione is very poorly absorbed and
when you take it, it breaks down very
quickly. So, your body prefers that you
make it. And so, now the question is,
how does the body make this? What does
it need to make it? Well, it needs a
couple amino acids like cyine and
glycine from animal meat, especially red
meat, can help you detoxify. In fact,
it's a necessary building block. But
also, this one tiny trace mineral called
selenium. A trace mineral is a mineral
that's needed in very tiny amounts.
Okay, I'm talking micrograms, very tiny
amounts, but it's involved in a lot of
important things. One of the most
important things is the activation of
glutathione. When I've done other videos
on selenium, I've always talked about
the thyroid, right? The activation from
the T4 to the T3. And what a lot of
people don't realize is that if the
thyroid is underfunctioning,
it cannot make bile. If you cannot make
enough bile and you don't get the flow
of bile that goes down here, you cannot
detoxify. Bile is the primary route of
how these toxins get eliminated through
the intestinal tract. And without a good
functioning thyroid, you can't make
enough bile to allow this to happen. And
this is why people with hypothyroidism
get constipation. You can't get rid of
excess estrogen. But it's not just the
production of bile. It's also the flow
of bile requires a good functioning
thyroid. This is why selenium is so
important for not just the thyroid but
for detoxification. Even the contraction
of the gallbladder requires a good
functioning thyroid. And if someone has
a low functioning thyroid, they tend to
get gall stones. And so what happens,
this bile is supposed to get released
into this little tube into your small
intestine. Right at the level of the
small intestine, there's a little valve
that's supposed to release it. That
little valve is also connected to this
thyroid. So we need a good thyroid to
allow this whole thing to happen. What
are some good sources of selenium? The
best source is Brazil nuts. All you
really need is two Brazil nuts a day to
get all of the selenium you need. Eggs
are another good source of selenium. if
they're high quality eggs. Organ meats
are another source. Cruciferous
vegetables do have some selenium in
them. Also, shellfish and certain
seafood has selenium. And if you think
about certain fish that have higher
amounts of mercury, they usually have
high levels of selenium to bind and
neutralize that mercury. This is why
selenium is so important. But here's the
big problem. Modern-day soils just don't
have near the amount of selenium that's
needed. And so a lot of things suffer.
Our ability to detoxify, our ability for
the thyroid to work, the ability for our
immune system to work. So again, it's
not just about this toxic overload. It's
about a failing detoxification system
because you don't have the raw material
to allow glutathione to work. But I just
want to emphasize one more time the
importance of this bile in the ability
to detoxify because a lot of times
people don't realize this important
connection. Also, if you decide to go on
a detox, I highly recommend you either
take some bile like something called
Tutka, maybe a few days before you do
that detox. So that way when you start
releasing some of these toxins in the
liver and they come out, you have enough
bile to transport them out. So many
people that I know and I've done videos
on this, they do a detox without putting
attention on bile and everything backs
up in the liver and they have a lot of
pain underneath their right rib cage.
The pain refers up to their neck and
their head. They get headaches,
especially on the right side of the body
and they're like, "What's going on?"
Well, you're getting a lot of toxicity
coming through here, but you don't have
enough bile to release it. So, the whole
thing just backs right up. And also
realize there's two types of bile salts.
You have the bile that's made by your
liver, but you also have a lot of bile
that is made by your own microbes lower
in your digestive tract. And so,
microbes make bile, too. And then the
whole thing gets recycled. You recycle
like 90% of your bile. And so another
missing piece of the puzzle is not
having enough of the right microbiome to
make your bile. So you have to look at
the whole system and understand it.
Okay, do I have enough bile? Is my
thyroid working? Do I have enough
selenium? Do I have a healthy gut
microbiome to be able to make enough
bile to have this whole thing work?
Because as we get more and more exposed
to plastics, forever chemicals,
pesticides, insecticides, junk foods,
etc., we have a couple choices. We can
live in a bubble and completely try to
avoid all of it, which is really hard.
Or why not just build up your
detoxification system with the right
precursors so you have enough of the
right antioxidant to deal with this
overwhelming toxicity that we're living
And